Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surfshark más en un momento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
máxima tensión aquí visualpolitik ya os
hemos contado como las relaciones entre
Washington y real no pasan por su mejor
momento de hecho llevan años de capa
caída y lo cierto Es que las cosas cada
vez están peor la vieja Alianza la
antigua sociedad la relación especial
entre
riate y Washington comienza a hacer ya
cosa del pasado y sabéis que en cierta
forma este gráfico explica perfectamente
el motivo os hemos hablado de ello un
montón de veces durante años Washington
garantizó la seguridad de la casa Saúl
la casa real saudí a cambio de que este
país regar el mercado mundial con un
suministro abundante de petróleo y a
Wall Street con los propios petrodólares
que generaba el negocio fue algo así
como un matrimonio de pura conveniencia
ningún tratado o pacto de defensa mutua
une o ha unido nunca a Estados Unidos
con Arabia saudí pero pese a ello todo
el mundo estaba completamente convencido
de que si la casa Saúl hubiera tenido
algún problema Estados Unidos habría
acudido raudo en su ayuda incluso Aunque
eso hubiera supuesto emplear todo su
músculo militar y todo eso por no hablar
de los miles de consultores militares
norteamericanos que entrenaban y en la
práctica apoyaban al ejército saudí
sin embargo la revolución del fracking
lo cambió absolutamente todo de repente
Estados Unidos se volvió casi
autosuficiente en cuanto al consumo de
petróleo Y entonces Pues digamos que
comenzó a ver orienta medio con otros
ojos y claro entonces llegó el divorcio
pero un momento porque esta historia ya
nos la hemos contado en un pasado vídeo
que os dejo en la descripción Así que
entonces La pregunta es por qué estamos
Otra vez hablando de Arabia saudí y
Estados Unidos Aquí en visualpolitik
Pues básicamente porque el día 5 de
octubre Los Reyes del petróleo árabe
hicieron oídos sordos a las reiteradas
peticiones de la casa blanca y
anunciaron todo un bombazo energético y
también político la OPEP Plus acuerda el
mayor recorte de la producción de
petróleo desde el inicio de la pandemia
Es probable que el movimiento para
reducir la producción diaria en dos
millones de barriles incremente los
precios y ayude a Moscú y aquí tenemos
que destacar varias claves por un lado
la crisis energética y el freno al
comercio de gas y petróleo con Rusia ha
hecho que el golfo Pérsico vuelve a
convertirse en un proveedor
indispensable para occidente por ejemplo
las importaciones de gas y petróleo
europeas desde el golfo han pasado en
menos de un año desde el entorno del 10%
a más del 20 es decir que se han
duplicado Y eso eso le ha dado un enorme
poder de Mercado a los jeques las
petromonarquías lo saben y ahora quieren
sacar tajada en este momento todo el
mundo necesita petróleo del Golfo todo
el mundo necesita Arabia saudí y a los
emiratos árabes Unidos algunos en
Washington definitivamente no se dan
cuenta de que hay un nuevo golfo y que
ya no aceptamos órdenes de Washington
abdulk kalea profesor de política
emiratí y es que amigos amigas nos
penséis que hablamos de poca cosa
el dinero está entrando a es puertas en
el Golfo Pérsico hablamos de decenas y
decenas cientos de miles de millones de
dólares extra en concreto el fondo
monetario internacional habla de unos
ingresos extraordinarios para los
exportadores de oriente medio y Asia
central de 320.000 millones de dólares
tan solo en 2022 320 mil millones y si
en otras ocasiones los jeques apostaron
por contener las subidas del precio del
crudo para castigar sobre todo a los
productores de fracking ahora las cosas
parecen completamente distintas digamos
que los jeques quieren ante todo
rellenar las arcas reales lo más rápido
que le sea posible y eso es exactamente
lo que están haciendo y también el
motivo que escriben para querer mantener
el precio del barril de brent por encima
de los 100 dólares ahora bien la
cuestión es que esta no es la única
consecuencia Geo económica y política
hay otra muy importante que tiene que
ver directamente amigos amigas la medida
aprobada por la conocida como Pet Plus
de recortar la producción de crudo
mundial en dos millones de barriles
supone todo un espaldarazo para el
kremlin justo además cuando accidentes
están las puertas a probar su tope al
precio del petróleo Ruso y como veremos
eso no ha pasado elegido absolutamente
por nadie y la pregunta es están los
jeques llevando a cabo un gigantesco
rescate de Rusia atentos
Pero antes
dadme un solo instante porque tenemos
que hablar de internet internet internet
está lleno de hackers cookies que no
queremos tener y cada vez más
restricciones queréis ver páginas web de
cualquier país sin ningún tipo de
bloqueo queréis navegar por internet con
seguridad pues no lo penséis más Usa tu
nuevo VPN como surfshark VPN creedme el
tema de la ciberseguridad se lo toma muy
pero que muy en serio por ejemplo
surfshark tiene una herramienta que se
llama cleanweb que bloquea todos los
popas de propaganda que es por donde se
cuela más Bots y muchas de las cookies
que no queremos tener por si todo esto
fuera poco con una misma cuenta de
surfshark podrás registrar todos los
dispositivos que quieras que quieres
navegar con seguridad desde tu smart tv
desde tu móvil desde tu tablet o desde
tu ordenador no hay problema puedes
hacer todo esto con la misma cuenta de
surfshark Y por supuesto tenemos una
oferta especial para todos vosotros que
seguís visualpolitik si utilizáis el
código politik podréis disfrutar de un
83 ciento de descuento más tres meses
extra totalmente gratuitos tenéis el
link en la descripción y ahora sí
adentrémonos en las turbulentas intrigas
políticas de oriente medio
[Música]
tormenta en Washington
en Washington y particularmente la Casa
Blanca lo tienen muy claro los audíes
fueron los grandes culpables de que la
OPEP decidirá recortar su producción de
petróleo y la verdad que lo hicieran
Justo a las puertas de las elecciones de
mitad de mandato en Estados Unidos y
justo cuando peor lo estaba pasando el
régimen de Putin en la Guerra de Ucrania
es algo que consideran casi como un
chantaje lo que por otra parte no ha
sorprendido a casi nadie y es que veréis
durante la campaña electoral Joe vaivén
dijo que Arabia Saudita era un país
paria y que como tal lo trataría desde
el despacho vale esta fue la respuesta
del actual presidente al brutal
asesinato del periodista llama al
casogui sin embargo la invasión rusa de
ucraneal le obligó a hacer de tripas
corazón de repente occidente necesitaba
encontrar alternativas para así poder
castigar al kremlin cortando las compras
de petróleo ruso El problema es que eso
no resulta Tan sencillo tras años de
poca inversión en la industria el
mercado del petróleo y del gas estaba
terriblemente tensionado así que al
presidente de Estados Unidos y a otros
muchos mandatarios internacionales Pues
no le queda otra que ponerse en marcha
para encontrar fuentes alternativas
incluso por el camino Washington estuvo
dispuesto a atender la mano a países
como Irán o Venezuela con pobre hasta la
fecha todo se ha dicho
[Música]
El caso es que de esta forma los grandes
productores del Golfo volvieron a
convertirse en los actores clave de toda
esta novela político energética y por
eso A mediados del mes de julio el
propio Joe biden visitó a Mohamed Bin
salman en Arabia saudí no fue el
encuentro más amistoso y caluroso del
mundo pero como gesto marcaba un punto
de inflexión la Casa Blanca Estaba
dispuesta a reiniciar sus relaciones con
riats y este país se unía activamente a
la gran coalición internacional contra
Rusia o si al menos tomaba medidas para
enfriar los precios del petróleo y con
ello parte de las presiones
inflacionarias que tan duramente están
castigando a medio mundo
sin embargo dos meses y medio después de
la visita Se confirmó lo que casi todo
el mundo ya sospechaba que el viaje fue
un rotundo fracaso Así que lejos de
anunciar un incremento en la producción
la OPEP Plus liderada por Arabia Saudita
y por la propia Rusia lo que anuncio es
exactamente todo lo contrario y eso
podéis creerme A desatado laira en
Washington sobre todo cuando además tan
solo cinco días antes de anunciarse la
medida enviados de la Casa Blanca
viajaron directamente hasta ría para
pedirle al gobierno de Mohamed que no lo
hiciera pero ni con esas y la pregunta
es exactamente por qué demonios han
tomado esta decisión las petromonarquías
del Golfo Pues bien esta pregunta la
responderá muy pronto en si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de información
financiera demutativos si no lo conocéis
echar un ojo porque seguro que lo
encontráis muy interesante de momento
por nuestra parte nos vamos a centrar en
las consecuencias y sabéis que las
reacciones no se hicieron esperar
[Música]
varios senadores incluido Robert
Menéndez el presidente del poderoso
comité de relaciones exteriores del
senado han pedido ya que se congele
cualquier cooperación con Arabia saudí
incluida la que se dé en el campo
militar Así mismo varios senadores y
congresistas tanto demócratas como
republicanos han anunciado ya su firme y
decisión de impulsar una nueva
legislación que suspenda las ventas de
armas al país árabe e incluso ahora está
sobre la mesa la posibilidad de que
tanto la casa blanca como el propio
congreso reactive en el conocido como
proyecto de ley no peck un proyecto de
ley con el que se busca perseguir
sancionar y exigir responsabilidades a
las compañías petroleras que sean
propiedad de gobiernos que forman parte
de un cartel del petróleo este sería sin
ir más lejos el caso de aramco la
todopoderosa petrolera saudí
la propia casa blanca parece ahora
dispuesta no solo a cambiar su política
exterior en relación al golfo sino
también incluso su propia política
energética para Estados Unidos Así que
si hasta ahora la administración vaiden
a priorizado la transición energética
eso podría estar cambiando por completo
amigos amigas el fracking vuelve a estar
de moda vamos a trabajar con nuestros
aliados estadounidenses para aumentar la
producción y asegurarnos de que tenemos
la capacidad de refinamiento suficiente
vamos hookstein asesor de energía de Joe
biden sea como sea si algo está claro
meridiano Es que la decisión de la OPEP
Plus supondrá más dolor para las
economías occidentales y especialmente
para la vieja Europa que decir verdad
Últimamente no lo está pasando nada bien
[Música]
pero aún con todo esto no es lo peor lo
más preocupante es que el recorte de la
producción justo cuando peor lo estaba
pasando Rusia en Ucrania y a las puertas
del Invierno Parece ser un claro rescate
para el régimen de Vladimir Putin y una
medida de presión contra occidente Y eso
eso amigos sí que resulta muchísimo peor
lo que Arabia saudí hizo para ayudar a
Putin a continuar liberar su
despreciable y viciosa guerra contra
Ucrania será recordado durante mucho
tiempo por los estadounidenses Jack
Summer político demócrata y líder de la
mayoría en el senador no vemos ninguna
razón por la que las tropas y los
contratistas estadounidenses deban
seguir proporcionando este servicio a
los países que están trabajando
activamente en contra de nosotros si
Arabia saudí y los emiratos árabes
Unidos quieren ayudar a Putin deberían
encomendarse a él para su defensa
comunicado de los congresistas
malinowski son que Einstein y Susan
Wilde y la pregunta es está la OPEP
realmente apoyando a la Rusia de Putin
atentos
el abrazo del oso
en Viena en la reunión de la opeplus que
decidió el recorte de producción hubo
dos grandes protagonistas el ministro de
energía saudí abdula Cid salman y el
Primer Ministro de Vladimir Putin
Alexander Novak un tipo que días Antes
había sido por cierto sancionado por
Estados Unidos la presencia del vicepre
Primer Ministro ruso sometido a las
sanciones de Estados Unidos para
discutir el endurecimiento del
suministro de petróleo de Cara a un
invierno en el que Rusia ya ha
dinamitado sus exportaciones de gas a
Europa Envía un claro mensaje Roger
daiwán analista del standard and Push
global commodity inside a ver seamos
claro
el recorte de la producción no es una
cuestión política sino que solo se trata
de negocios sin embargo una cosa está
muy clara los estados del Golfo no han
condenado la invasión rusa de Ucrania y
no han secundado ninguna de las
sanciones y ahora tampoco han escuchado
a su antigua Aliado norteamericano y
aquí amigos amigas hay una cuestión que
no podemos dejar pasar el país que con
mucha diferencia más beneficiado va a
ser por los recortes de la producción es
precisamente la Rusia de Putin Por qué
pues ahora lo Vais a entender
perfectamente
[Música]
A diferencia de Arabia Saudita emiratos
irako Kuwait los costes de extracción
del petróleo ruso son mucho más altos de
hecho se estima que de media son el
doble que los de árabes saudí por
ejemplo hablamos de más de 40 dólares
cada barril y eso no es todo las
sanciones internacionales y la falta de
compradores han hecho que Rusia está
vendiendo su petróleo a países como la
India y China con descuentos de hasta 35
dólares sobre el precio de cotización
global y además como también podéis ver
en pantalla redirigir las ventas rusas
de petróleo a mercados tan lejanos de
las fuentes de producción como China o
la India implica también plazos mucho
más largos y por tanto mayores costes
logísticos es decir 40 dólares de costes
de extracción 35 dólares de descuento
comercial y mayores costes logísticos
todo esto supone que por debajo de los
80 dólares Rusia deja prácticamente de
ganar dinero con sus exportaciones de
crudo Y sabéis a qué precio estaba el
barril de brent justo antes del anuncio
del recorte de la producción Exacto
estaba tocando la Barrera de los 80
dólares y es que veréis la fuerte
desaceleración económica que se está
viviendo en China y en general la peor
marcha de las economías occidentales
hizo que el precio del petróleo cayera
cerca un 20% pasando de los 100 dólares
en el mes de julio a los 80 finales de
septiembre Y eso tal y como hemos visto
suponía un terrible castigo precisamente
para Rusia sin embargo ahora con el
recorte de la producción las cosas
cambian
[Música]
Sí vale ahora habéis saudí ingresará más
dinero por barril pero también extraerá
y venderá menos barriles la diferencia
será positiva pero no tan grande en
cambio para Rusia el incremento los
precios del petróleo supone una
diferencia abismal por debajo de los 80
dólares el barril y el kremlin
prácticamente no gana nada y amigos
amigas No olvidemos que en 2021 los
beneficios del petróleo sufragrán el 45%
de todo el gasto Público de Rusia Es
decir para meterle el dedo en el ojo a
Washington para reforzar la posición de
la opeplus como el cartel que fija el
precio Internacional del crudo y para
beneficiarse de la guerra y esta vez las
petromonarquías del Golfo han decidido
al menos por ahora alinearse claramente
con Moscú Y es que no se trata solo de
Arabia saudí emiratos por ejemplo
también ha secundado alegremente el
recorte de producción quizás no sé tenga
algo que ver que duváis haya convertido
en la nueva meca y en el nuevo Refugio
de moda para los oligarcas rusos 21 de
septiembre del 2022 los rusos huyen a
Dubai los precios de los billetes se
disparan a 5000 dólares a medida que
aumentan las tensiones por la amenaza
nuclear desde que diera comienzo la
Guerra de Ucrania a los rusos y
particularmente los millonarios rusos
abalanzado sobre Dubai para comprar
propiedades establecer sus negocios y
poner a salvo sus fortunas por ejemplo
en los emiratos comprar una propiedad de
750.000 unos 204.000 dólares al cambio
te asegura tres años de residencia y por
supuesto las inversiones más grandes
pues te pueden asegurar mucho más tiempo
y aunque las cosas ya no resulten tan
fáciles como antes para los rusos sobre
todo lo que respecta a las operaciones
financieras Lo cierto es que se las
están ingeniando para utilizar a Dubai
como una de sus nuevas bases de
operaciones luego que por supuesto está
contribuyendo a que esta ciudad esté
viviendo toda una nueva época dorada ya
sabéis los negocios son los negocios
Claro que un momento porque puede que
esta vez a los árabes la jugada no le
salga tan bien atentos
la partida
[Música]
a ver uno de los grandes errores que
suelen cometer los dictadores y
autócratas de todo tipo y sobreestimar
siempre sus cartas claro como suelen
estar rodeados de aduladores y vivir en
una especie de burbuja donde su palabra
es la ley no pocas veces terminan
arriesgando más de la cuenta esto es
exactamente lo que les pasó a dictadores
como San José o más recientemente al
propio Vladimir Putin en Ucrania Pues
bien Ahora podría pasarle algo muy
parecido al líder saudí Mohamed Por qué
pues por ejemplo porque esta última
jugada deja muy claro que este país ya
no es de ninguna forma un socio
confiable para occidente
es casi seguro que la producción
petrolera de Estados Unidos y del resto
del mundo crecerá con fuerza Durante los
próximos años al tiempo que también se
acelerará el desarrollo de energías
alternativas incluida la nuclear es
decir la medida de riad puede terminar
reduciendo los beneficios futuros del
país al mismo tiempo la cooperación
militar con Estados Unidos resulta
fundamental para el reino no solo para
poder acceder a los equipos más modernos
y defenderse el caso de un país como
Irán sino también para mantener los
miles de puestos de trabajo que se han
creado en el país
y desde luego si algo ha dejado claro la
Guerra de Ucrania es que si hablamos de
equipos avanzados no hay alternativa a
los suministros occidentales y sobre
todo a los estadounidenses y además y
sobre todo Arabia saudí Lleva años
contándonos que va a invertir
gigantescas cantidades de dinero para
diversificar su economía sin embargo
para que eso ocurra Al menos que ocurra
de verdad necesita Sí o sí cooperar
comercialmente con los países más ricos
del mundo es decir con las empresas de
occidente y medidas como está como
alinearse con Moscú pues no contribuyen
lo más mínimo ese objetivo en cualquier
caso lo que queda claro es que esta vez
las petromonarquías han retado al
gigante norteamericano La pregunta es
qué queréis que ahora los Estados Unidos
podrán los países occidentales evitar
volver a caer bajo la influencia de los
Países Árabes crees que esta medida es
puramente comercial como afirman los
audios o por contra estamos ante un
claro Movimiento Político déjanos por
aquí abajo tus impresiones y abramos
debate Y por supuesto si este vídeo te
resultó interesante No olvides darle
like y suscribirte si es que aún no lo
has hecho Ah Y échale un vistazo a
subshark muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]